Jadi konsep fundamentalis ini pada dasarnya terkait dengan
konsep pengukuran dalam mekanika kuantum
sebelum mekanika kuantum dikembangkan
sudah umum diketahui
oleh para ilmuwan bahwa kalau kamu punya sistem yang
berada dalam suatu keadaan tertentu
dan kamu melakukan pengukuran padanya, kamu bakal dapat
hasil yang sudah pasti
dalam mekanika kuantum itu nggak berlaku lagi, kamu bisa punya
sistem yang berada dalam keadaan yang terdefinisi dengan sempurna
tapi ketika kamu melakukan
pengukuran tertentu padanya, kamu bisa dapat hasil yang acak
jadi biar aku bisa menjelaskan konsep itu, lebih baik aku
perkenalkan dulu konsep superposisi
superposisi adalah konsep yang sebenernya nggak aneh-aneh amat
ini didasarkan pada suatu sistem yang menampilkan
beberapa kombinasi linear dari keadaan-keadaan secara
bersamaan, dan kamu bisa bayangin
seperti misalnya gelombang radio yang membawa
banyak frekuensi berbeda, itu nggak ada
yang aneh dari sisi fisika klasik
yang bikin superposisi punya rasa kuantum adalah fakta
soal pengukuran sistem itu
jadi aku mau jelasin dengan contoh
bayangin kamu punya sistem berisi panah-panah
dan kamu menyiapkan sistem itu
supaya semua panahnya mengarah ke kiri
terus kamu pergi dan
menanyakan pertanyaan: kamu ke atas atau ke bawah?
dan karena panah-panah itu mengarah ke kiri, itu bisa
diekspresikan atau dideskripsikan
sebagai superposisi antara
atas dan bawah, kamu bakal dapat
hasil lima puluh persen ke atas
dan lima puluh persen ke bawah waktu kamu nanya apakah kamu ke atas
kamu dapat hasil itu dari sistemnya
lalu kamu bisa menyiapkan dengan
keadaan sistem yang berbeda di mana setengahnya
mengarah ke atas dan setengah lainnya
mengarah ke bawah, dan kamu nanya pertanyaan yang sama
dan kamu dapat hasil yang sama
ini adalah dua sistem yang sangat berbeda
tapi kamu sudah kehilangan informasinya
untuk jumlah yang lumayan besar
gimana caranya kamu bisa tahu apa bedanya?
sistemnya sangat berbeda
karena pada kasus pertama kamu menyiapkan sistem dalam
keadaan murni, dan ada pertanyaan yang bisa kamu
tanyakan ke sistem yang bakal kasih kamu hasil yang deterministik
bukan acak, dan pertanyaan itu adalah kamu ke kiri atau ke kanan?
dia bakal bilang seratus persen ke kiri
pada kasus kedua, nggak ada pertanyaan yang bisa kamu tanya
yang kasih kamu seratus persen hasil pasti, karena itu adalah campuran
hasil yang pasti karena itu adalah campuran
jadi kalau kamu nanya ke kiri atau ke kanan
jawabannya bakal acak karena setengahnya ke atas
setengahnya ke bawah, kalau kamu nanya atas atau bawah
sama aja, bakal jadi lima puluh persen
gimana hubungannya ini dengan keacakan?
kamu bisa bayangin bahwa ini
mirip dengan lempar koin, bakal ada kepala atau ekor
tapi ini nggak kayak lempar koin sama sekali
karena waktu kamu lempar koin
satu-satunya alasan kamu nggak tahu hasilnya
adalah karena kamu nggak tahu
energi yang dipakai buat lempar koin itu, sudut momen, dan
kondisi sekitar di ruangan itu
dan seterusnya, jadi kalau kamu tahu semua
variabel-variabel itu, kamu bisa prediksi kepala atau ekor
variabel-variabel itu tersembunyi dari pengamat
dan selama bertahun-tahun para ilmuwan berpikir ada
variabel serupa dalam mekanika kuantum yang akan
memunculkan diri sebagai keacakan
dan itu baru terbantahkan sampai
karya seminal John Bell di tahun enam puluhan yang benar-benar
membuktikan bahwa itu bukan kasusnya
dan sekarang setiap fisikawan
mengakui bahwa nggak ada teori variabel tersembunyi
yang kompatibel dengan mekanika kuantum
jadi memang benar-benar bahwa waktu kamu mengukur suatu sistem
alam mengungkapkan hasilnya
nggak peduli seberapa lama aku pikirin itu, tetap aja
aku rasa itu menakjubkan